nicaise morose bonjour bonjour à vous
bonjour à vos auditeurs et
téléspectateurs la bonne année à tous
vous êtes maire de sainte-luce depuis
vous avez 58 ans et vous vous présentez
pour la deuxième fois vous savez la tête
de liste de l'association citoyenne
lucéenne qu'est ce qui vous motive pas
écoutés nous avons avec les camarades du
conseil municipal entamé un travail que
nous a autorisés à que nous autoriser à
mener les électeurs du cn en 2014
électeurs lucien que ne cesserons jamais
de remercier d'ailleurs de nous avoir
autorisé à engager ses actions pour
sainte luce et nous entendons poursuivre
dans la voie en entreprise l'heure est
au bilan
des actions menées quelles sont les
actions qui ont marqué votre première
mandature mais écoutez il ya il ya des
choses qui se voit il ya des choses qui
se voit moins
parmi ce qui se voit que tout le monde
voit que c'est plus est une commune très
active à la fois dans ses projets
d'investissements que dans son animation
mais il y a aussi toute une organisation
poupe à ôter le changement que nous
avons engagées que je crois que les
lycéens constate il a fallu aussi
travailler avec le personnel communal
réorganiser les services communaux un
style et un autre état d'esprit au sein
des services communaux donc ce sont des
choses qui sait le travail interne qui
est tout aussi important que
l'investissement les routes etc
il ya des grands projets que nous avons
achevé tels que la médiathèque 1 c'est
un projet à cellou a achevé nous avons
réussi à faire ça et parallèlement nous
avons réformé notamment notre manière de
venir en aide à ceux qui d'entre nous
ont besoin de l'assistance et du soutien
de la collective collectivité communale
nous avons par exemple mis en place les
pis si solide hier qui nous permet
d'accompagner les gens n'ont pas
seulement de les aider en leur douleur
mais de les accompagner en apprenant en
les accompagnant dans la gestion de leur
budget par exemple entre autres projets
il a tellement qu en cinq minutes on
pourrait pas les aborder tous alors
votre mandature ortiz a aussi été
marquée par la démission de votre
première adjointe oui si vous en parlez
aujourd'hui et ça fait déjà deux ans et
que vous avez bien que ça n'a pas fait
de vagues à sainte-luce ce qui est ce
qui n'est pas important ce qui est
important c'est pas les gens au sipal
ceux qui occupent les postes de pouvoir
communal
c'est ce qu'on fait avec le pouvoir dont
on dispose donc la démission l'ancienne
première adjointe a décidé de
démissionner bon elle a ses raisons
c'était pas ça l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'était mener l'action proposée est
promise au lui c est ce que nous avons
fait comment vous allez vous aborder
cette campagne 2010 20 vôtre
votre adversaire jean fils de nylon ne
sera pas candidat mais il y aura un
représentant de pays c'est quand même
assez particulier on peut parler de
joseph les colocs qui n'est pas candidat
le goûter comment je demande comment
vous allez aborder cette prime
ecoutez jean wiener n'est pas mon
adversaire je suis à l'opposé dans les
enseignes d'accor thème de d'orientation
politique de pratiques politiques de
comportement politique je suis d'accord
mais c'est pas mon avis assez vous le
voyez bien à chaque fois que je viens
dans une mission il faut qu'on ne parle
d'eux enfermé non moi je parle de cette
luce donc ce qui m'intéresse et
sainte-luce et me poser la question de
savoir comment je les aborde cette
campagne oui je l'abordé sereinement
parce que nous avons travaillé mais je
crois que nous avons démontré au lycée
et nous en nous l'avons fait avec eux
d'ailleurs nous devons les remercier à
la fois le personnel communal que la
population s'y avec eux que nous avons
pu commencer à mettre en place ce que
nous souhaitons en termes de politique
citoyenne pour la commune de salon les
grands axes de votre programme
le programme à venir venir ben écoutez
nous allons continuer à revoir à
réformer l'administration communale ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que
l'administration communale soit
véritablement au service de la
population vous savez il ya ce qui me
plaît le plus ce qui me satisfait le
plus c'est quand quelqu'un me dit
monsieur le maire avant ne venait pas à
la mairie parce qu'on avait le sentiment
d'être mal reçus tandis que maintenant
on est reçu on se sent reçus à la maison
plus avec le sou et c'est ça c'est un
élément c'est beaucoup plus important
pour moi que l'investissement qu'une
route qu'on doit refaire bien les audois
tout à fait mais ça c'est un élément
important nous voulons poursuivre dans
cette orientation là et puis nous allons
aussi continuer d investissements qui
sont en cours d'engagement ou alors
qu'ils sont programmées telles que par
exemple revoir l'éclairage public dans
sa totalité y lit à revoir le réseau
d'éclairage public à cette puce à la
fois pour faire des économies d'énergie
et à la fois pour une belle satisfaction
de la population il ya tellement de
choses à dire et au sens de ces mots et
donner l'occasion
dans l'avenir il ya le dossier de la
place de 10h qu'on appelle communément
fond larion les habitants de la plage
ont-ils reculer leur clôture
écoutez ça ne peut pas faire partie du
projet communal puisque ce n'est pas
être douce et communales
la plage c'est sur votre territoire
voilà mais si vous avez ya le jerry
sloan et non pas du tout il faut
participer à une réunion avec la
sous-préfète
oui ou non il y passe ou le territoire
de sainte luce mais comprenez bien qu'il
y à des propriétaires qui sont devenus
propriété suite à une vente de l'état il
y a trente quarante cinquante ans même
70 fois l'état a vendu son domaine ya
plus de cinquante pas géométriques la
halle et a vendu son domaine privé et
puis il ya le domaine public qui jouxte
c'était un privé et il y à une
réglementation qui dit qu'il faut
installer il faut comme de là quand il
est possible de le faire
d'instituer un une servitude littoral
mais vous nous commune de cette liste il
faut appliquer la réglementation
respectant le droit de chacun des
propriétaires de ceux qui ont le droit
de passer et l'état aussi doit doit
jouer son rôle
nicaise mon aux autres je vous remercie
déjà merci à vous et puis à bientôt
alors dans le cadre de l'élection de la
campagne électorale
[Musique]